hello everyone this game was a
suggestion from a subscriber and not
only is it an interesting game it
features one of my favorite openings in
the Evans gambit so of course I agreed
to do it but before I show you the game
I just want to tell you I put a link in
the description below
it's a link to the video I made to thank
everyone for my channel reaching 1000
subscribers I'm pretty sure most of you
haven't seen that video and it's a
pretty cool tile game so you know it
will give you a chance to see how my
channel looked like when I had 1000
subscribers and how it looks now so I I
was pretty surprised when I saw this
video yesterday so you know you're
probably not gonna enjoy the video but
it's definitely a great tall game it's
called not bad for a dead man but okay
that being said here we have a game that
people are referring to as the Brazilian
immortal it was played by a Clow called
us viana one of the greatest brazilian
players from the end of the 19th century
and he was well known throughout europe
for his romantic style and plenty of
sacrifices and he's playing against our
gusto Silvestre pies de barros I'm
pretty sure I pronounced that wrong but
okay and like I said it's the Evans
gambit and a lot of people have analyzed
this game a lot of engines have analyzed
this game and like many of the games
from the Romantic era I mean a engines
do find reputations I mean even in
immortal games of Adolf Anderson in Paul
Morphy but that is no reason for us not
to enjoy them so let's see the game
called us Vienna has the white pieces
and he plays efore we have e5 Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 Bishop to c4 and the
Bishop to c5 so we have the Italian game
the Joko piano or is it yoko not really
sure and here we have B for the end the
Evans gambit this time for real
Bishop captures on b4 and maybe some of
you have seen the game between grease
chicken calls and grease chip played the
Evans gambit against Carlson and Carlson
refused the gambit with Bishop to b6
and ended up losing that game so you
know it's not that easy to to refuse the
Evans gambit you know best go by that
old couple Blanca saying that gambits
are refuted by accepting them so we have
a bishop captures on b4 and c3
that's the idea of the Evans gambit
given up the b-pawn to gain control the
center we have Bishop to a5 Black has
some more options here he can play
Bishop to c5 you can play Bishop to e7
you know depends it's a personal
preference so Bishop to a5 and now d4e
capture son d4 we have castles and d6
it's it is possible to capture upon on
c3 but you will very rarely see anyone
who is willing to play with the black
pieces to grab the 3rd pawn because
after you grab the 3rd pawn
then after Queen to b3 attacking f7
Queen to f6 defending Bishop to g5
attacking the Queen Queen to g6 Knight
captures on c3 black white is fully
developed and if you enjoy a passive
position like this you know you might
enjoy playing this with black but knight
Knight to d5 is in the air you know the
rooks are ready to jump into the game
black will probably have to give up the
bishop here and after being captures
it's a you know I don't know some people
enjoy this position for why some enjoy
it for black so CC which fits you better
but okay in the game after castles d6
was played we have Queen to b3 now I'm
the f7 pawn Queen to f6 defending and E
5 now attacking the Queen and
threatening to open up the e-file for
the rook
so D captures on e5 and we have rook to
e1 now threatening to grab this pawn
with knife captures and after Knight
captures push f4 Bishop to d7 and we
have Bishop to g5 now I wouldn't attack
on the Queen Queen to f5 and now comes
Knight captures on e5 you can't capture
the hanging bishop here because if you
capture a bishop you get Knight captures
on f7 we'll check
the knight is defended from the bishop
on c4 so after Queen to e7 you lose the
Queen and the rook so this would be this
isn't possible for black so after Knight
captures on e5 Knight captures and if I
was played a now f4 defending the bishop
and threatening to capture the knight f6
now and this is by far the best move for
black now not capturing the night but
Queen captures on b7 threatening to
capture the rock on a8 rook to d8 and we
have F captures on e5 f captors and g5
of course and now rook to f1 e six might
seem like an interesting idea although
after bishops way for white has nothing
here he has no way of continuing any any
kind of an attack so after F captures
and g5 looked to f1 attacking the Queen
and Queen captures on e5 was played and
this was actually the move that gave
white the advantage after this room to
have one move blacks best bet is
actually to capture the rook with the
Queen rook Queen captures rook on f1 and
after Bishop captures Bishop to b6 and
and black is okay here
why does have a rook and the piece for
the Queen sorry black has and he has a
couple more extra pawns but it it would
be very hard for whites to play this I
mean like will develop very soon which
moves like 97 castles and white still
has to develop his rook his knight and
the Queen on b7 isn't really a great
piece but in the game after rook f1
Queen captures on e5 was played and now
white does get some initiative Knights
the d2 I will heal Knight to e7 rook now
to e1 as what if 97 wasn't played rugby
one would pin the Queen so 97 we have
rook 81 now attacking the Queen Queen to
c5 and Bishop to f7 with check now King
to f8 and Bishop to g6 and here black
replies
with the bishop to f5 unfortunately King
to g8 is impossible if you flicking to
g8 you get Queen b3 and you're getting
checkmated you have to block this 25
Queen captures Knight captures and out
Bishop to f7 check King f8 Bishop
captures on d5 would check the rooks are
occupying the files the king has nowhere
to go so Bishop has the block and rook
captures on f5 this is checkmate
so after Bishop the g6 check Bishop to
f5 was played Bishop captures on a5 9
captors and i-5 and now Knight to e4
attacking the Queen and also trying to
kick the Queen away from the defense of
the knight on f5 and here we have
another critical position here black
plays Queen to b6 what black could have
played was Queen to d5 and after
something like after something like
Queen captures on d5 and rook captures
okay you can win back the piece with the
g4 but black doesn't mind after D
captures on c3 rook captures rook
captures and GG actress and King to f7
white did win back the piece but black
has too many pawns and this e3 pawn is a
monster so this wouldn't really go in a
White's favor
so after Queen to d5 white would
probably have to play something like
rook captures on f5 with check but after
Queen captures and rook to f1 black can
calmly capture this rook Queen captures
and after King captures D captures on c3
and black definitely has compensation
for the Queen here although he still has
to develop this rook the problem is this
rook is undeveloped and the King is in
an open board against the Queen and the
night so probably black Saudis but he
decided not to go for this so after 9420
b6 was played here we have rook captures
on f5 would check King to g8 and black
thought okay I gave back the piece and
now you know I'm just gonna trade Queens
and it's gonna be a nice nice
in game for me but he missed this move
or or or so he thought
Knight to d6 and what is this doing well
first of all it's defending the Queen
here and what do you play here is black
and this is the position that was
analyzed by many players by many great
players by even more engines and you
know there are all sorts of conclusions
but I'm just gonna show you what what I
think is important in this position
black played D captures on c3 which was
a mistake
what's black but black should have
played is Queen captures on b7 and after
Knight captures Bishop captures on c3
and if you play something like rook to
e7 you get rook c8 and after rookie
actress Angie 5d3 now the bishop is
protecting g7 and after something like
rook to D 5 D 2 and black is perfectly
fine here there there is nothing for him
to you know worry okay maybe rookie 3
but then Bishop to f6 and the rook still
can't capture the d2 pawn because Bishop
to g4 will will pin the rook so this
would definitely be okay for black but
after this Knight to d6 move black
played D captures on c3 checking the
White King we have came to h1 and now h6
was played and in this position
unfortunately black doesn't have Queen
captures on b7 anymore if Queen captures
on b7 now then after Knight capture some
b7 and c2 this does come with an attack
on the rook on e 1 but now after Knight
captures on e5 on a5 getting rid of the
bishop and the rook to d1 white is
defending this perfectly would look F to
F 1 so in this position Queen captures
on b7 was impossible so black tried age
6 and this is where white now gets
everything he ever wanted White's idea
is he wants to get his Queen from b7 to
e6
he wants to check
the black king girl with the queen from
east six and how does he do this well
it's a it's a pretty cool maneuver
he plays Queen to d5 would check King
has only one move King to h7 now plays a
queen to e4 threatening all sorts of
nasty discoveries after this rook moves
of course you can't play g6 because
after the simple rock f7 checking j18
Queen captures on g6 this is checkmate
so after this Queen two before move King
has to go back to g8 and now Queen to e6
check a check and white accomplished
what he wanted to he checked the black
King with the Queen on e6 came to h7 and
now the brilliant move that's the reason
why white one if his Queen to check the
King on e6 rock to f6 and this is this
is brilliant you can't capture the rook
if you captures rook then the simple
Queen to f7 is checkmate and if you
don't if you play something like rook
captures night or even Queen captures
night then you get this brilliant rook
captures on h6 check the King can't
capture as the Queen is protecting the
rook the g8 square is guarded by the
Queen so we have to capture the rook and
after G captures on h6 again you get the
Queen to f7 checkmate
so after rook to f6 black tried rook H
to f8 now making room for the King on h8
but now this was just a very simple
tactic Queen to a5 check the King goes
to g8 and now rook captures and I fade
rook captures on f8 and now the create
Brazilian finisher Queen captures on FA
King captures and erupted d8 checkmate
and the beautiful checkmate if I might
say so it wouldn't help a black if he
played King to h7 this awful was very
quickly to Queen to a5 check g6 roughly
7 check King h8 and Queen to c8 this is
also checkmate so yeah unfortunately
for black there was no defense whatever
he played so yeah that's the game this
is the game many many referred to as the
Brazilian immortal I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank this is I
forgot to I forgot to update my
interface so I didn't include the latest
donations in the video but I will do it
in the next video
surely so yeah like I said I do hope you
enjoyed it and do check to check the
video I put in a link in the description
below as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon